I mean you can't call that a baguette
really or you jail in France my name is
Gus Raquel and the owner of lamprey
memory being French I've been baking my
inch'allah today we're gonna taste some
free bread from restaurant or an
American I'm very excited
[Music]
it's pretty light stuff pillowy that's
good this smells like battery is very
very very dense almost four years she
but you drink
cheese you did you did you didn't no
cheese no cheese no better it's about
the flavor is good texture from the
outside is very nice then it becomes
like almost too fluffy very though we
would have like maybe two stars to start
with
Red Lobster Yangtze quoted in the song
so it should be good it's very only the
cheese I guess be squid is very dance
it smells like there is like better and
herbs it's not very cheesy I think they
look good on a shelf I would pick one up
well not this one but the other one was
cute three stars because it's free and
cheesy and crazy
[Music]
it's very pillowy in a good way but no
crunch if you push it it becomes mushy
we don't smell like anything really
it'll just be like warm bread one wrap
is always good you can take the words
whatever when it's warm it's good this
is very sweet please like sugar or maybe
a bit of honey on Bowl acid this is so
sweet it's pure sugar
you got my Beachbody you come the data
the flavor is okay more like a brioche I
think three stars for the effort it
comes with burner to make it better
everything is better with better
[Music]
early South that's a good thing ficus
comfrey the better makes it more
interesting no easy for the pleasure now
the inside we back to this mushy Airy
let's hear the taste and this one is
very sweet - you know kind of good way
but not in the way I was expecting this
is the spread gonna makes it even
sweeter yeah no Beach for me this summer
[Music]
it's not for me I would give maybe one
star I like the idea that restaurant
America give red to people I think what
we would love to see is more artisan
bread everywhere French people
we just Sicilian Kerry and
[Music]